Hey guys how's it going?! So I bought this
at the craft store the other day when I
was looking for some crafts
because I love to craft , you know (Jenna: Wait)
(Jenna: But this is a baking video)
yes well I where I'm not so sure i would
call this or classify it as a baking
video because it's called yummy nummies
mini kitchen magic I've never seen this
before when I got up to the checkout counter
the girl was like is this edible I'm like I
have absolutely no idea I
(Jenna: Super Tiny!) Yes!!
Artificially flavored, it's clearly very very
healthy for you, dinner delights, it's 6 plus
(Jenna: is there anything in here this like air)
It's Magic!! Mix, Bake, Enjoy! (Jenna: It's gonna have to be, cause there's nothing)
(Jenna: in that box, ah right well, It makes 10 mini pizzas)
I've had this for like four weeks and (Jenna: OH!)
I've wanted to open it and I just
didn't I wanted to wait, I wanted to see the real aww
(Jenna: This is authentic pizza)
Authentic reactions
(Jenna: Right from the box of air, magic. 6 and up)
I've also get a bunch other ones but i think it's going to be like
sort of a
hey who wants to come over and make a yummy
nummy (Jenna: well i hope the instructions are on)
(Jenna: the inside, cause this box is)
(Jenna: Yes, they are) Yess! (Jenna: Nice, Ooh Super Tiny) Super
O look at, O MY GOD!
O MY GOSH!!
(Jenna: Wait I feel like I'm ratatouille, with the little teeny tiny)
That is my favorite movie (Jenna: It's my favorite movie, no it's not)
I went to pixar back In the day when they were working on that film
(Jenna: Excuse me, It's not my fault I'm not that old)
*Jenna Laughing* *Justine is offended*
(Jenna: Look at the sauce, look at the cheese) *Both Giggle*
look how freaking cute this is, Ok look (Jenna: Pizza Party)
(Jenna: First remove the tray, packets, utensils from packing using)
(Jenna: a scissors, it says use a scissors)
(Jenna: A Scissors) I'll get a scissors (Jenna: Use the Scissors to cut the kitchen)
(Jenna: Magic Tray along the indented lines)
Like, right here
I mean that's indented. (Jenna: Yeah)
(Jenna: Use the scissors)
Does it say an adult should do that?
(Jenna: No, Wait there's an)
(Jenna: an asterix) What's it say?
(Reading Together: Any steps, requiring use of scissors or)
(Jenna: or microwave should be performed by an adult)
(Jenna: Should we go find an adult?)
It's too late, I'm here your here (Jenna: Cool)
(Jenna: In tray one)
(Jenna: mix seven scoops of crust powder with)
(Jenna: 3 scoops of water)
WHAT?? (Jenna: Seven Scoops)
But which scoop?
*Justine Making weird noises like a mouse*
(Jenna: I think this scoop)
Do you wanta get some water ready? Like in a cup or something?
(Jenna: *Mumbling* Yeah yeah yeah)
Here we go!
(Jenna: Mix 7 Scoops of crust)
No, Oh 3 Water! What would I be doing without you?
How many was that? That was 3?
(Jenna: I wasn't counting) Shoot!
(Jenna: 4,5,6)
Seven!
(Jenna: Cool!)
One
Two
Three
This is ridiculous
(Jenna: Divide the mixture evenly)
(Jenna: Into trays, 2,3,4 and 5)
I think I might, wait are we sure, this is like (Jenna: Yep)
This is our little dough, Oh My God these are so cute!
That's not very much (Jenna: Divide it evenly)
Okay, ah right. *Giggles*
(Jenna: Into these tiny trays 2,3,4,5) *Justine Giggling)
*Justine Still Giggling*
Shut up. (Jenna: So take the little spoon) *Justine Bursts out Laughing*
(Jenna: Put it in the little spoon hole)
(Jenna: Give me, that)
(Jenna: Just use your finger)
I don't want a touch it, it's really gross!
(Jenna: Honestly it's fine)
*Justine Makes weird noises*
(Jenna: Ok after this, we have to microwave the crust for 10 seconds)
(Jenna: and allow to cool for 30 seconds) WOOW!!
(Jenna: Flatten the crust into the tray with your finger)
(Jenna: Oops, I did the before)
*MICROWAVE BEEP*
(Jenna: Your Frying your brain)
(Jenna: Ugh)
(Jenna: Maybe it'll help)
It's gone long ago
*MICROWAVE BEEP* WOW WOW WOW!!
They puffed up!
Wow! Oh it's hot! Oh God!
What are we supposed to do now?
(Jenna: flatten it with your fingers)
Oh God, It's so hot!
(Jenna: OH WAIT 30 seconds!)
*Both Burst out laughing*
(Jenna: Wait 30 seconds)
(Jenna: And then flatten it)
JEEEZZZ! My finger tips
I could go, I could go do illegal things
I don't have any finger prints now
(Jenna: Wait 30 seconds and then flatten it)
I LOVE BEING ILLEGAL!
(Jenna: Open the sauce, 022 packet)
That's the sauce packet?
(Jenna: Sauce is 022)
Okay, What do we do with that?
(Jenna: 4 and a half)
In six
(Jenna: I think so, I'm just doing what I want to do)
(Jenna: One and a half, and one scoop of water)
(Jenna: Mix Well) I'm ready, I'm ready to mix
(Jenna: I'm just gonna add a little bit more water) *Justine Mumbles*
(Jenna: How does that turn into sauce?)
(Jenna: Open the sauce over the four pizza crusts)
(Jenna: Place the pizza tray back in the microwave for 5 seconds and wait  1 minute to cool)
*Jenna makes high pitched noises*
(Jenna: Also the cheese packet)
It does look like jelly
(Jenna: Cheese 023)
(Jenna: While shes doing that)
(Jenna: Divide, one scoop of cheese)
How many seconds? (Jenna: O wait)
How many seconds? (Jenna: 10 seconds, oh 5 seconds)
(Jenna: Man, I'm full of lies today)
*MICROWAVE BEEPS*
WOW! Fresh, look at that! (Jenna: Divide one scoop)
(Jenna: This is just like fresh brothers)
*Justine laughs*
It's probably just a fresh
(Jenna: I like fresh brothers, sometimes)
I do too, but Matt
But this like, this about as fresh as fresh brothers
Is what I'm saying
(Jenna: Well I think they might be a little bit more fresh)
Can this one get a little more?
(Jenna: Yes I've got extra cheese)
Well I guess it's fine
It's fine, I'm patting it
Get outta there
How the heck?
(Jenna: Maybe it's not fully cooked)
So that's it right?
(Jenna: Serve your pizza, on the pizza peel)
(Jenna: And enjoy, Repeat steps 2 to 6)
look at all theses things, there's a sundae maker a donut delight
OH! guys, if you like this video please
let me know because if you do i'm going
to be making every single one of these things
(Jenna: Mini meal, lets go!)
Cheers! (Jenna: This can't even be)
*Sounds of Chewing*
Well it tastes like pizza, Like a sweet pizza
like I can't even say it's bad
(Jenna: Did you eat the whole thing?)
O, I'm sorry! I didn't realise I was supposed to portion myself
With my small tiny bite
Oh, I'm so full!
I'm on my Santa Clarita diet
(Jenna: It tastes Like a pizza gummy)
So how so we explain what this taste is?
So the consistency of the dough, is a little bit grainy
The sauce feels like, it tastes like a sweet jelly
(Jenna: Yeah, It's like a jelly)
But it still has... It's like a jelly if you put some spice in it
(Jenna: A fake pizza, like remember when you used to have those lunchables?)
Ugh, Don't throw lunchables under the bus like that
This does not taste like a lunchable
(Jenna: It's like an upgraded lunchable)
No, This is like a downgraded lunchable!
It's actually a really cool idea
I think this is kinda a cool little gift probably to like get
young children that are 6 plus. This is not sponsored by the way
I bought a bunch of these
(Jenna: Lets do the mini cupcakes, I'm ready)
I don't have them yet, I'll have to order them (Jenna: O)
Ok, Well get them and then let's talk)
Perfect!!
(Jenna: When Matt comes we'll be sure to add his reaction)
Ah right, we'll see you guys later! Thanks for watching! Bye!
(Jenna: Unless Mini Pizza's the death of us)
(What if this is was mini pizza poison?)
*Both Laugh*
I got poised at the craft store!
*ALARM RINGING*
Does that mean we're dying?
(Jenna: That's our time is up) Oh God!
Take me now
This is how I'd like to go
(Jenna: Take her I'm not going, I have to go to a Movie tonight!
John Wick 2 baby! Ok Bye!
(Matt: Cooking Videos?) Just try it!
(Matt: How long have you known me?)
But it's a fricking pizza!
(Matt: I smelled it and you said it was weird and I don't like it!)
Jenna! (Jenna: Try it) (Matt: No)
(Jenna: Everyone else did!)
(Matt: I'm not, I'm stubborn!)
Eat it Just try it!
Now it's cold!
(Matt: O Please) Just try it! (Matt: You Make me so upset)
Ok this will help you!
(Jenna: Your Gonna go and eat Movie snacks)
(Matt: I'm not eating Movie snacks)
Matt just try it your ruining the video!
I was like yeah, we're going to see what Matt thinks
and see it it tastes like fresh brothers (Matt: Can you tell me what it is first?)
(Jenna: It's a pizza) Cheese
i'll show you the box
(Matt: Ah right, I'll eat the dam thing!)
It's just a tiny mini pizza! (Matt: Oh)
(It's actually pretty good)
(Matt: Oh) I mean it's not like good but
it's not bad it's just a mini tiny pizza
it's doesn't taste good *Justine Laughing*
(Matt: What is that?)
It's a tiny mini pizza
(Matt: O, You weren't lying to me)
No!
(Matt: O, Ok)
(Matt: Can you actually eat it?)
Yeah!
(Matt: Oh My God, You shouldn't have eaten it)
*Both Laughing*
No We all tried it and it was fine
I mean it's not a good taste, but it's not like bad, it's just whatever
*PLAYBACK OF OTHER VIDEO*